today we'll take a look at the final two
of the six new classes in van helsing 3
the Bounty Hunter and the constructor
the Bounty Hunter is a long ranged
weapon specialist who relies on physical
damage and uses mechanical seekers to
track down tort son to mark his enemies
the constructor also likes to keep
distance from its enemies his biggest
advantage in battle is the vast gun
platform which summons his mechanical
allies and rains down destruction on his
foes the bounty hunter can explore
dangerous areas from a safe distance he
only needs to send out his
indestructible decoys to seek out and
mark enemies which will make them
vulnerable to attacks the decoys can
also be used to taunt enemies luring
them close and then the decoys explode
taking down the monsters with them the
constructor on the other hand sends in
his army of turrets ornithopters and
dismembered BOTS to do the dirty work he
can use the transmodulator ray to mark
the primary target for his companions
while he keeps dealing constant damage
the constructor can support his
mechanical army in battle with lead
storm which causes sustained damage for
a gradually increasing mana cost the
bounty hunter relies on skills that must
be charged like the precision shot which
needs three seconds to take aim but in
return it can kill enemies with a single
shot if a bounty hunter faces a larger
group of enemies he can use scatter
blast that adds two more projectiles
with each second it has been charged the
constructors most remarkable advantage
in battle is his gun plat
not only does it summon all of his other
allies but it also deals immense damage
with cannon blasts and turret gunfire
with certain masteries it can be
improved to fire additional homing
missiles and tear apart enemies with saw
blades from close range the Bounty
Hunter would rather fight with only lady
Caterina on his side when his enemies
are getting too close he uses missile
fault to reach shooting distance again
the constructor and the bounty hunter
will be tough enemies for the invading
monsters who lurk among the shadows or
go via destroy them or